the Mandalorian declared its intention
to hit its audience with twists and
turns of plenty with its first episode
alone an episode 2 titled the child
effectively doubles down on that notion
its final act out our jaws on the floor
and we're chomping at the bit to unpack
all of its implications before we do
however n just in case you somehow
missed the title of this video please be
advised that spoilers for episode 2 of
the Mandalorian follow be careful
YouTube the episode has our hero at last
escaped in our ball of seven with this
would-be target but everything is
changed with the revelation that said
target is an infant and a member of the
same mysterious race of the Jedi Master
Yoda the Mandalorians life has grown
infinitely more complicated after
lulling the audience into a false sense
of security with 15 solid minutes of a
seemingly unrelated fetch quest for the
Mandalorians ship parts the episode
answers the question we were naturally
led to ask after the pilot in shocking
fashion is the baby force sensitive like
Yoda if you listen closely during the
climactic scene you could hear the
Mandalorians creator jon favreau
laughing his face off because of course
the Yoda baby is force sensitive the
show chose to reveal that pact in the
most sweeping epic moment and an
otherwise very small and quiet episode
during an attempt to secure an egg from
a ferocious horned beast with which he
hopes to barter with the Jawas for ship
parts the baby uses the force to save
the Mandalorian as he grimly stares down
death at the hooves of said beast with
naught but a knife this completely
shifts the narratives paradigm and it's
quite unclear if the Mandalorian himself
understands what has just happened
there's a particularly sneaky bit of
exposition in the dialogue between the
Mandalorian and quill just before the
final ship repair montage when quill
asked that the baby was injured the
Mandalorian replies no at least not
physically well then ask the Mandalorian
to explain what happened again that he
doesn't understand and the Mandalorian
tellingly replies that he doesn't know
either the two never explicitly stated
but the Mandalorian has apparently told
quill how we retrieved the egg with the
last minute miracle the baby provided by
suddenly displaying its force abilities
we the audience of course know exactly
what happened and what it means but if
the Mandalorian is telling quill the
truth then the bounty hunter doesn't
know what the force is and he has no
idea what the baby is capable of and why
that's a pretty big deal and it could
have a massive impact on the Bounty
Hunter's actions going forward it's more
reasonable
then it seems at first blush that the
mandalorian would be ignorant to the
force consider its 25 years before the
ultimate fall of the Jedi Knights and
the rise of the first order
we're following a man living in the
outer rim and we know for a fact that he
is an orphan even fellow outer rim
dweller Luke Skywalker was completely
ignorant of anything related to the
force until obi-wan Ben Kenobi came
along so there's no reason to think that
the Mandalorian would be any more
knowledgeable on the matter the
Mandalorian is also well Mandalorian so
he probably has very little formal
education beyond his tactical and combat
training maybe were saved by an
indescribable feat of supernatural power
that can only be described as miraculous
you'd probably be a little shook and you
may even reassess your priorities it's
the classic bounty hunter conflict trope
the Mandalorian has now learned a little
too much about his target and it looks
like he'll be faced with a serious moral
quandary as a result we also shouldn't
forget that there is practically an
entire phalanx of bounty hunters looking
for the little force-sensitive tyke the
Mandalorian has successfully completed
the most difficult part of the task
removing the target from its secured
bunker and it has suddenly become much
much easier for these scoundrels to take
the baby for themselves the only thing
now standing between the infant and its
many pursuers is the Mandalorian who
should probably get used to having a
giant target on his back
none of his options at this point are
particularly attractive is the lure of
the best gar steal too much for the
Mandalorian versus the obvious moral
issue presented by handing the baby over
to an emissary of the Empire is his life
worth going rogue and protecting the
Yoda baby at all costs
[Music]
we can see that the mandalorian operates
according to a code of honor and respect
that best car steal though represents
not cash but a piece of his religion a
sacred item that not only provides him
with personal enrichment but the
opportunity to help his people in a
profound way for that matter it's worth
noting it remains suspiciously
convenient that the client presented the
mandalorian with exactly this form of
payment at a time that the bounty hunter
was shown to be particularly desperate
for work heading into the third episode
the Mandalorian is certainly between a
rock and hard place and it's being
painfully Illustrated for him that as
the client stated when he took the job
bounty hunting is indeed a complicated
profession check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Star Wars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]